you play a character who's sort of
inspired by this um
middle school band teacher did you have
somebody like that in your life
yeah um you know two weeks ago i was
going through my my
dad's old boxes and uh i found a note
on a napkin that was written in 1975
and um this this really kind woman in
portland maine
it just this is a stranger it walked up
to me and
i told her like i really love music and
she's like really what music do you love
and i name like all the artists i love
and the next thing i know she came back
the next day with my very first record
player
and these albums and i shared this note
on my instagram to show people that like
this woman had planted a seed to my
record collection because
pretty much you know the world the
people that know about me know that now
i have 200 000 records
and like a library of albums and i say
that you know the beginning of my record
collection starts with
this random stranger buying me a record
player and my first
three records you have this amazing
scene in seoul
between you and joe which i don't want
to give too much away but did you ever
have an interaction like that with one
of your family members where you
you realized just how sort of supportive
they were for you and your
sort of ambitions there was never a time
when i felt unsupported by my family
really
wow never my father was a dentist
and he would have loved it if i had
become a dentist
he would have loved it but he also
he had a great appreciation for theater
and actors
and music and uh when he
saw that that was
that was in me and he saw it at an early
age
when i was when i was young he saw it
he determined to support it part of
seoul is dorothea kind of giving joe a
shot
and i was wondering if there was anybody
like that in your life sort of as you
were growing up
or had you know ambitions of being this
amazing artist
who was there somebody like that in your
life the shots in life
they were they were more there may be
a director of a after-school summer
program
that i was in right now of all the
students he gave me the shot
to go to to represent the program and to
go to washington dc
and there i'm you know i'm roommates
with
young ladies who are from other parts of
the world
you know not just i'm just all i know is
the south
this little corner of the south that i
grew up but to find
to meet and eat and sleep and talk and
chat and observe
people from different who look diff far
different than
anyone i've ever grown up seeing you
know
you know i used to say i all i knew
growing was black people white people
and old people you know in florida
do you remember what the records were oh
that's the embarrassing part
okay so um
okay so she at the time uh
rufus and chaka khan's dance with me was
was really hot
um it was impossible to not be a jackson
five obsessive so she brought me uh
looking through the windows their their
fourth album
their fifth album and um and i think at
the time
neil sedaka and elton john's bad blood
was like
a major hit but i think i like that song
mostly because i love the way that uh
the logo looked i always judge records
on how the logo look
uh rotating on the 45 right so
uh yeah neil sedaka's label rocket mca
had a really cool looking logo when it
spun
on the turntable so i chose bad blood
by neil sedeka and elton john and so
i still have those records too at home
after my sophomore year in college
i had an opportunity to come to new york
city
to work with the negro ensemble company
for
six weeks in the summer i had never
been away from home except to go to
college
certainly not to a city like new york by
myself
my father was very upset about it he
tossed and he turned and he couldn't
sleep at night
and it really wore him out because his
children
were his jewels right treasured us he
really did but then it came down to the
wire and something happened
something happened within the family
dynamic
and when he saw how much it meant to me
and what it meant to me
my father dropped all of that
and was amazing yeah that's how he was
right and from and from that day
for sure he'd come to see anything i
anything i was in
if i was opening a door my father was
there
he gave me that shot it sort of it
opened up my
my brain it opened up my world he'd open
up my
you know my little now took me out of my
my little four cornered room